protesters defy kovid restrictions
banning protests to gather in their
thousands in central tunis
their angry president kai side has
dissolved tunisia's judicial watchdog
the supreme judicial council and his
latest law gives him near total control
over the appointment and dismissal of
judges
critics say he's now consolidated power
over all the country's institutions
the president has relieved some judges
of their posts dismissed others and
prevented them from objecting or
striking the judiciary that we resort to
is now under the control of the
president
g7 states in the un have voiced deep
concerns about syad's actions and his
increasingly authoritarian rule
the eu says its member states are
discussing cutting funding to tunisia
and tunisia's judges have been on strike
demanding independence for the judiciary
and the reinstatement of the watchdog
kai's side supporters and many lawyers
however support his decision and accused
the council of failing to root out
corruption that they say is rife among
judges
these demonstrators say they're afraid
that kai side is dismantling the state
there are no longer any independent
constitutional institutions today
yesterday was the last of them before he
decided to establish a temporary body
for the supreme judicial council
but a movement calling themselves
citizens against the coup say they're
not giving up
the political and democratic movement of
the street continues and with the same
objectives and the same approach
critics say that kai side is gambling on
gaining total control over tunisia at
the risk of losing the financial support
of the g7 and eu
but this process shows that many
tunisians are prepared to defy his
authority and fight against dictatorship
that they fought so hard to overturn 11
years ago
eliza faltman al jazeera tunis